my name is Michael Sullivan and I have a
story I think you're gonna want to hear
I knew his father he'll do the program
is called oil-for-food the UN would
manage the sale of Iraqi oil and he used
the profits to provide humanitarian
relief to alleviate the hardship do
anything I can to help your child it
sickens me to have to stand there and
listen to your nice Justin cutter
Central Intelligence we think oil for
food is being gained for private gain
possibly with help from the inside which
is where you are aware spying for you
just keep your eyes and ears open that's
all there are some after service fees
I'm pretty sure they're kickbacks
I took this job because I want to help
people come on kid wanted a career in
diplomacy while you're missing a golden
moment your predecessor
he was murdered you need to be very very
careful you know it's very dangerous for
you to be in this godforsaken desert I'm
escorted well consider this a courtesy
get in the car
for as long as I can remember I wanted
to make a difference we've been through
this Michael this is quite worthless
Moscow Beijing Saddam has funds mafia
greed no sorry you are naked
they can save the world trust me
[Music]
[Music]
you